[Music]  what we know  senior chief kelly is the third member  to be attacked  three perps are dead  also killed was his wife  they better hope he doesn't survive why  is that  he is more dangerous and effective than  any man we have in the field  he took everything from me  these were foreign attacks on u.s soil  we have to respond  i'm gonna make it right  there's something inside of me that i  can't turn off  a part of me that won't stop for  anything  no remorse  as it occurred to you that perhaps john  kelly  has done something we can't  some situations aren't thinking outside  the box  give me your name you are supposed to be  dead give me a name  [Music]  [Music]  you